in der geschichte von abraham und der
opferung seines sohnes geht es um einen
tötungs akt der mit dem willen gottes
vollzogen werden soll
da gibt es aber auch die andere ältere
geschichte im bibel und koran die von
der tötung eines familienmitglieds und
zwar diesmal gegen den willen gottes
erzählt kein er schlägt seinen bruder
abel und begeht somit den ersten mord
der menschheit bei mir im studio sitzt
nun alfred bodenheimer sie sind leiter
des zentrums für jüdische studien an der
universität basel
herr bodenheimer wenn ich über religion
und gewalt höre dann habe ich den
eindruck den menschen kommt immer zuerst
die geschichte von abraham und der
opferung oder der geplanten opferung
seines sohnes ihnen sehen weniger aber
die geschichte von kain und abel täusche
ich mich da die geschichte von abraham
das opfer oder opfern soll hat schon
eine sehr spezifische bedeutung in der
religion
sie geht davon aus dass ein gott der als
lebensspendende als gütig in der regel
wahrgenommen oder von den religionen
übermittelt wird hier eigentlich den
befehl gibt ein vater sein kind zu opel
und dem vater der gottesfurcht damit
gleich sechs diesen befehl auch
nachvollziehen zu wollen und das
erschüttert natürlich eine ganz
besondere weise und bringt natürlich
religion und gewalt dadurch durch die
offensichtliche einmischung oder
eigentlich die initiative gottes noch
viel stärker religionen gewalt
miteinander in beziehung
wir sehen diese geschichte also als
etwas stoßen das an offenbar weniger als
die kain und abel geschichte
ich kann mir vorstellen dass einigen
zuschauern diese kain und abel
geschichte vielleicht auch nicht mehr so
ganz präsent ist können sie die kurz
skizzieren kain und abel sind das erste
brüderpaar der biblischen geschichte
also die kinder von adam und eva die
sich zerstreiten es geht um ein opfer
das zunächst karin bringt ein
frucht opfer von den erträgen sei noch
ernte und gott nimmt das opfer nicht an
und abel der jüngere bruder bringt
danach ein opfer von den erstgeborenen
seien noch die härten das wird von gott
angenommen und das führt zu einem
konflikt und dessen endeca in den abel
erschlägt also es ist diese bevorzugung
gottes gegenüber dem opfer das eine im
vergleich zum opfer des anderen haben
wir bekommen da nicht auch den eindruck
einer gewissen ungerechtigkeit water
aussieht können wir nicht heute
verständnis haben für einen kein der
eine gewisse frustration daraus auch
erlebt ja natürlich wurde oft danach
gefragt warum nimmt eigentlich bot
dieses opfer nicht an und in die
initiiert damit indirekt natürlich auch
wieder das gewalt geschieht die exegese
hat sich darüber sehr viele gedanken
gemacht warum das so ist
es bleibt letztlich auch irgendwo
ungeklärt und die frage ist natürlich
auch hier die gilt eben als dienst an
gott auch dass damit sich abfinden dass
etwas was man tut nicht unmittelbar zu
anerkennen geführt hat also diese frage
die der mensch sich vorstellen muss ist
religion etwas was erfüllung gewisser
maßen generiert oder ist religion auch
etwas was uns damit vertraut machen soll
mit frustration umzugehen die auch aus
der religion selbst sogar entstehen kann
nun wenn ich noch einmal diese beiden
geschichten vergleiche in der geschichte
bei abraham und der opferung hält ja
gott dann letztlich abraham davon ab
dieses opfer zu bringen hingegen gott
hält kein nicht von dem gewaltakt ab es
zu tun
wie erklären sich da die gelehrten
dieses unterschiedliche verhalten von
gott ich denke man muss mit einem
gottesbegriff arbeiten der
nicht ein gott nicht als intervention
instanz primär anschaut gott schafft
eigentlich den menschen mit dem freien
willen die welt zu gestalten und seinen
mitmenschen umzugehen und auch das böse
zu tun und auch andere selbst zu töten
dass der umstand dass gott sozusagen
seinen eigenen befehl ausbremst in
diesem einen fall mit adam und isak will
noch nicht heißen und wir müssen es leid
reister geschichte zu genüge dass gott
verhindert dass menschen unschuldig von
anderen gewalt zugeführt wird oder dass
sie getötet werden
gehen wir zurück zu der kain und abel
geschichte kein wird gewalttätig aus der
frustration heraus aus der
unbeherrschtheit heraus was erzählt die
geschichte über das menschenbild
denn kein ist ja der erst der erste
mensch auf erden geboren wurde also wir
könnten da auch in einen konflikt kommen
und sagen das sagt eigentlich über das
menschsein nichts gutes aus ich glaube
nicht dass die bibel über die menschen
das menschsein sehr viel gutes aus sagt
menschen in der bibel leben dauernd in
konflikten auch in teilweise
gewalttätigen konflikten nicht nur bei
arbeits und auch anderswo
und ich denke die bibel erzählt um zeigt
uns eigentlich gerade wie in einer welt
in eine menschheit die an und für sich
dem konflikt ausgesetzt ist und
vielleicht für den konflikt fast sogar
gemacht ist wie man mit diesen
konflikten lernen kann umzugehen bei
kain und abel ist es noch nicht gelernt
worden und entsprechend dramatisch geht
diese konflikte auch auf nachfragen denn
die gelehrten wie mit dieser geschichte
umzugehen ist wie bedeuten sie die
exegeten die jüdischen exegeten es gibt
in der jüdischen exegese eine große
rahmenerzählung die versucht zu zeigen
das eigentlich bei und appliance sehr
viel größeren interessenkonflikt
ausgetragen haben also dass es auch
darum ging wie teilen wir die welt und
uns beiden auf also wenn man sie als
erste menschen
sid die eigentlich die welt mehr oder
weniger zu ihrer verfügung gehabt hätten
wir gar nicht primär um diese frage des
abnehmens des opfers also dies es gibt
natürlich sehr viele unterschiedliche
erzählungen aber es gibt eine erzählung
die sagt also jeder versucht sein
territorium abzustecken
und sie werden sich da ab oder momente
nicht einig es gibt auch die frage ob es
um eine frau gegangen ist ja also das
muss ja auch fragen geben damit dass
sich am ende vor platzen kann die
menschheit und das der kein den
eigentlich auch betrogen hätte weil sie
gekämpft hätten unter kein eigentlich
unterlegt waren dann gesagt hat wir
wollen das abbrechen und dann als der
abel von dem ablesen umgebracht hätte
daher keinen sehr negatives licht
getaucht die geschichte lässt sich aber
wenn wir den magnetischen also den
ursprünglichen hebräischen text lesen
der uns überliefert ist auch als
geschichte einer sprachlosigkeit lesen
denn es gibt diese stelle die übersetzt
eigentlich heißt und kein sprach zu abel
und sie gehen aufs feld und er tötet ihn
aber was er ihm gesagt hat das steht
nicht
nun gibt es in der griechischen sektor
kindheit der dieser fassung gibt es noch
ein eingefügten satz also wir gehen aufs
feld oder so sagt er
in der hebräischen überlieferung gibt es
dieses was er ihm gesagt hat nicht und
es ist so als wenn er anhebt zu sprechen
aber letztlich nicht fähig ist zu
sprechen sondern seine sprache besteht
nur noch in der gewalt
man kann diese geschichte als eine
geschichte der sprachlosigkeit zwischen
menschen lesen wo die einzige sprache
nicht mehr die werber alle ist sondern
nur noch die gewalt anzuwenden ist es in
der auffassung der exegeten keine
absicht seinem bruder umzubringen ist es
mord oder ist es eher so etwas was wir
als juristisch betrachtet fahrlässige
tötung eigentlich betrachten müssten das
aus einem affekt heraus dieser totschlag
geschieht
es ist eine art totschlag und das
interessante ist ja auch dass er für
diesen totschlag und gut ja auch nicht
mit dem tod bestraft wird
dieses berühmte sogenannte kainsmal die
schönste geschichte geht weiter gott
fragt dann bin kein wo ist dein bruder
abel und kein sack den berühmten satz
ich weiß es nicht bin ich meines bruders
hüter dass ich es wissen soll also diese
sehr ironische rückfrage nachdem er in
getötet hat und gott weiß natürlich was
geschehen ist und sagt das blut seines
bruders schreit zu mir aus der erde und
im prinzip wäre die strafe das in
dasselbe widerfahren wäre das experiment
menschheit prinzip bedeutet sie einen
kein bekommt dann dieses in sogenannte
kainsmal an dem man ihn erkennen soll
wissen soll wäre ist und wird zu einem
unsteten wand hoch auf der erde also
seine strafe besteht eigentlich nicht
darin ein selber jetzt dem tod geweiht
zu sein sondern er wird ein lebenslang
unstet durch wanderer werden
sie sind ja nicht nur leiter für
jüdische studien und akademiker sondern
sie sind auch literatur wissenschaftler
und autor und haben mehrere drei bücher
der kriminalroman herausgegeben eines
ist kein opfer und der protagonistin
ihren kriminalromanen ist der orthodoxe
rabbiner gabriel klein der sich in
diesem buch ja auch mit der frage
beschäftigt was dieses opfer auf sich
hat und wie es dem keinen weiteren er
geht meine frage dieses keims opfer
diese zeigt ja auch irgendwie dass gott
diesen bund aufrechterhalten will also
irgendwie ist es aus heutiger sicht zwar
schwer nachzuvollziehen dass der mörder
trotzdem geschützt jetzt durch gott auf
der anderen seite was sagt das aus
kein ist glaube ich eine letztlich sehr
komplexe figuren es gibt ein wunderbares
gedicht dass ich mein buch auch irgendwo
nicht direkt aber am zitiere ich spreche
nicht direkt darüber aber das motiv
komfort eines israelischen dichters der
nicht mehr lebt dann partys ist er der
eigentlich versucht
zeigen dass aus der sicht kein abel auch
das bessere opfer gewesen sein könnte
also kein ist eine figur die vielleicht
auch danach sucht wie komme ich denn
doch auch dazu gott richtig zu dienen
und das missverständnis dass sein opfer
das er ein nicht ein opfer nicht von
tieren war es um ein opfer von ein
veganes opfern wenn man so will nicht
angenommen wurde dass aber der abel
tiere geschlachtet hat es könnte ihm
signalisieren offenbar muss man ein
lebendiges töten und welches lebendige
könnte wertvoller sein als mein bruder
abel und dadurch eigentlich als einem
missverständnis heraus denn anderen
tötet um das bessere opfer zu bringen ja
also man kann die geschichte auch so
lesen und dann wird die gestalt des kein
nochmals einer sehr viel komplexer und
der mann nicht einfach nur das böse
unterscheiden kann sondern die in ihren
kampf mit sich selbst und vielleicht in
ihrem missverstehen dessen was eine
göttliche geführte welt ist und was ein
dienst an gott sein könnte zum täter
wird jetzt wenn man sich in dieser
situation von kein versetzt dann fragt
man sich ja was hat er danach mit seinem
leblosen bruder angestellt da endet
eigentlich dann die geschichte in der
bibel gibt es in der jüdischen tradition
hier noch irgendeinen fortlauf der
geschichte
nein und der name ab level auf hebräisch
bedeutet wenn man ihn übersetzt
eigentlich auch vergänglichkeit und auch
die selbe boot ist bekannt aus dem
prediger buch reckless yuste ist also
alles ist eitel der berühmte
formulierung des predigers eitelkeit
über eitelkeit alles ist eitel das wort
eitelkeit oder vergänglichkeit ist hell
dass dort auch das ist dasselbe wie der
name des abel
das heißt abel steht auch wirklich etwas
was da ist und vergeht und nachher auch
keine spuren hinterlässt
auch keine kinder und gar nichts ja das
ist irgendwo auch eine eine gestalt die
im prinzip dazu dient zu zeigen wie die
welt ohne ihn weitergeht etwas ironisch
gesorgt
das ist sehr interessant weil es nämlich
in der islamischen tradition die
geschichte gibt dass der keim
verzweifelt war und ich wusste was er
jetzt mit dem leichnam machen sollte und
zwei krähen beobachtet hat die wo die
eine die andere auch tötet und dann die
erde auf schaut um sich zu begraben und
daraus leiten die muslime beispielsweise
den ritus ab dass menschen beerdigt
werden
meine schon bald letzte frage ist wie es
dann der verkauf in der menschheit sind
wir jetzt eigentlich nachkommen von kai
wenn wir das so weiter denken also
keiner schlägt einen bruder das heißt
die nachkommen wären ja dann eigentlich
alle aus der linie von kein die haben ja
dann noch ein kind adam und eva haben
dann noch ein kind den set der dann eine
große nachkommens voll gehabt und wir
können uns natürlich dann zurück klebl
sagen nein wir stammen vom dritten ob
der mieter ganzen geschichte überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat aber natürlich
interest klein auch nachkommen die
teilweise auch bedeuten dass dann
leisten und er selber wird auch zum bau
erbauer von stecken wird teilweise auch
ein in der bibel eine art vom ursprungs
figur der kultur tätigkeit des menschen
in diesem sinne sind wir allein als
kulturell gewesen wenn wir das biblische
herleiten wollen schon auch nachfolger
kainz interessant übrigens das in den
60er jahren ein psychologe leopold sohn
die sich große gedanken darüber gemacht
hat dass moses im prinzip auch ein
nachfolger von keines moses er schlägt
ja auch in ägypten einen menschen und
muss dann deswegen fliege erschlägt ihn
weil er sieht dass er einen israeliten
quält und so weiter und es wird ihm
eigentlich nicht als schande gerechnet
aber diesen effekten diesen impuls
jemanden totzuschlagen weil man etwas
für nicht gerecht hält der kommt auch
dort vor und er versucht doch eigentlich
zu zeigen wie aus einem
kein moses wird also wie wir eine
entwicklungsgeschichte auch bei menschen
vor sich gehen kann dass der mensch ein
potenzial hat aus dem kein auch
herauszuwachsen aber dieses potenzial
des keins das steckt in uns allen drin
sie nehmen ja in ihren kriminalromanen
diese biblischen geschichten auch auf
lassen den rabbiner sie auch
interpretieren oder die wochen
abschnitte darüber abhalten und und
auslegen
ist es ihnen auch ein anliegen dass wir
uns vielleicht wieder vermehrt mit
diesen geschichten im allgemeinen auch
befassen
ich denke diesen geschichten steckt
einfach unglaublich viel von der
menschlichen natur drin und es kam
natürlich an ein anliegen sein dass die
menschen sich damit befassten ich denke
aber vor allem wenn man beginnt sich
damit zu befassen beginnt man auch zu
merken wie viele handlungsmuster und wie
viele konflikte hier im prinzip schon
abgehalten worden sind in dieser
abgehandelt worden sind in dieser
biblischen geschichte und weil der
robbie natürlich eine figur ist die
darin lebt fallen ihm zunächst einmal
gerade diese dinge ein um mit problemen
mit gewalttätigkeiten uns weiter den er
selbst ausgesetzt seien realität
irgendwie fertig zu werden
ich denke das nicht kennen der bibel ist
eine art von defizit mit problemen
umgehen zu können
die hier natürlich nicht die man nicht
lösen kann wenn man die bibel kennt aber
die man irgendwo vielleicht auch besser
einordnen kann wenn man negative
vorbilder dafür besitzt ihr letztes buch
heißt der messias kommt nicht
sie sind gekommen sind die sternstunde
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
dieses gespräch
bodenheim 6 ist privatsache ist es nicht
widerspricht schelin el fekki die
bekannte ergibt dies britische
wissenschaftsjournalistin hat über viele
jahre männer und frauen in der
arabischen welt zur sexualität befragt
sie fordert ein umdenken und eine
rückkehr zur sinnlichkeit in der
sternstunde philosophie ist sie jetzt
bei meiner kollegin barbara bleisch zu
gast